Hello and welcome to this video, we're going to be carrying on the exercise here and all
we're going to be doing is we are going to be creating the smart object actor itself
and connecting everything up to it.
So for this smart object itself, we can actually select any class which is below the actor,
but for this we're just going to be working with an actor direct.
We're going to call this BP Chair.
I double clicked and open this up.
You'll see we have a standard actor here and we're going to need a couple of odds and
salts in this.
First thing that we're going to need is the static mesh itself.
So if I come in here and I search for static mesh in the components, see we have a static
mesh.
Then I'm going to call this SM underscore chair.
To call this static mesh, I'm going to search for the same one SM underscore chair, then
you should see that we have this chair here.
Okay, so we have our physical representation.
Now I'm going to add in a couple more things.
First thing I'm going to add in is a box collision.
And this isn't a necessity, but what you will find when you are working with smart objects
is that we have a little bit of a challenge often with collisions in order to get the
static mesh to sit cleanly onto a chair.
At some point, some collision needs to be turned off.
And in this case, we can turn off the collision on the chair itself.
And I only had a collision find it, just so it's a very small collision.
I'm going to scale down here.
I'm going to use this as a method of preventing other people from walking through the chair
as it's going on.
So if you can do that, that just means that we can turn off the collision on the chair
and it will, and it, and our navigation is still, is going to be infected.
Okay.
So let us jump in for this collision.
We need to change the collision preset because these are set by default to overlap dynamic.
And we want to put it down to block all.
So that gives us our back collision.
Go helping with that.
Now what I'm going to add is our smart object component.
You can see here, it is down here on the, as we're going through, smart object here.
So in our smart object, we need to provide it with a smart object definition.
And you can see that we have our chair, smart object definition chair.
So we're going to use that on that.
Now I'd like to actually put this in place, but we have not fully set up our smart object
definition.
So I'm going to double click and open this up.
So here we are in our smart object definition for chair.
And I know we can do a more advanced one in the second exercise.
For this, I would just like you to add in the Sundiana slot.
So you can see at the top here, we have had slot.
And you can see that this is going to have none below it here.
But what we want to do is we want to connect up the default behavior definition to the
push pride and do a drop down.
We go work with the gameplay behavior smart object definition and a third one down here.
We're going to do the drop down and we're going to go with the GBC sitting down.
So that's everything there connected up.
What we should see when we go back to our BP chair, so you can now see that we have
our slot is visible.
Now I'm going to move it a little bit further forward.
But until we get the animation running, it's going to be a little bit hard for us to figure
out where this slot needs to be.
So I will leave that as it is all the time being.
Now there's one more thing that's let's do with this chair.
And that's to add a interface.
So we've always point you should have used interfaces quite a lot.
They define a method for us to communicate between actors without having to know necessarily
what the actor is.
Before this interface, I'm going to come to class settings and implement interfaces.
I'm going to search for BP smart object interfaces.
And with that, we will be we will be given a couple of functions that we can override
down here that we would do when we get to the coding side of this.
With that, I will save and comply and I can drive each chair into the world.
So we'll finish the video there.
In the next one, we're going to be doing some of the actual coding.